on the night of his glorious return an
incredible force bought from the bay
seems to destroy his dreams
leaving him beaten battered and bruised
but from the ashes with the arm of a God
he led a revolt of historic proportion a
dominant display unlike anything we have
ever seen fifty-yard bombs dropped with
insane precision laser beams with
tantalizing touch we witnessed a king a
hero we witnessed the one-legged goat
from the hills of chico california born
in the wake of brett bow down to his
majesty marvel at his grace and always
respect the First Amendment Aaron
Rodgers is the greatest quarterback we
have ever seen I it filled me with such
joy I was filled with such pain yeah I
don't know if I've ever gone through a
roller coaster of emotions right him
being in the injury tent fine it's an
injury tent right him being on a cart
yeah
the cart is the death sentence pretty
much it's a different death sentence
though when you can walk to the cart
which he did oh and he sat in the front
seat I literally looked at my whole
front seat front such a good insight you
know that's where I was like okay well I
mean it's I doubt it's torn they meant
no putting him out there for his torn so
that's where I had hope I didn't think
he was coming back in the second half
and then you got a little bit of word I
got a little word and then we saw him we
saw him down 20 to nothing yep
they're down 20 to nothing and I'm gonna
be honest I like Aaron Rodgers more when
he's injured when Aaron Rodgers is
injured and he sits on that back step
and he just kind of looks around goes
pew pew it's it's like this incredible
target practice that I've never
witnessed before yeah apparently he goes
into the huddle and the first thing he
says to the team is do your jobs and
I'll handle the rest are you kidding me
I know are you kidding me told the
defense if you just holdin to zero we'll
win in the second half and he's like
well the held in the six but we made
some place all right so what what were
you watching that game I was high
everybody by the way sorry hey it's
Tuesday I was sitting there with my wife
first of all my wife at the end and the
Notre Dame game yeah I was asked about
the Sunday Night Football game and I
said I think this is gonna be a really
close game and Rodgers gonna win it very
alive and my wife was like oh I want you
to be right about your prediction first
time ever and I was like it's really not
that big of a deal I predicted it I'm
wrong a lot but so he goes down Aaron
Tito's right and my little boy walks in
I'm like fill up [ __ ] Aaron Rodgers
dessert and he's like no really yeah I
hurt his knee and he's like oh is it bad
dad and I was like I don't know it
sucked I don't think it's too bad yeah I
think it'll be a back this season yeah
so so there's a em first and now he sit
down and start watching TV watch the
whole second half no no yeah and he went
to bed at 20 to 10:00 that's bad parents
a sorry kid's got to grow his growing
boy what he wants to be Aaron Rodgers
one day he has to go to sleep know he
used to see Aaron Rodgers to be come on
we're trying to raise young Phillip Sims
here anyway so anyway so know as he's
hurt though all I'm doing is thinking
about I'm going to shred Mike McCarthy
and the Packers in the morning here we
go but players get hurt when all you
asked the [ __ ] guy to do is
everything all the time I mean that's
what I was sitting there going I mean I
wanted to make whoa great offseason they
really move really
went back really went back and fixed
that offense throwing up the pages yeah
on the new office looks like the same
[ __ ] to me it did look like the same and
it is the same [ __ ] but he can make [ __ ]
into the greatest Caesar salad ever I I
think the thing that it took me a while
to realize and I don't think people have
comprehended the first touchdown to
Geronimo
Alison yeah people I think are taking it
casually like that was a 25 yard pass or
a 30 yard pass like Andrew Luck had a
similar touchdown for his first
touchdown his was 32 yards something
like that
that fellow from Aaron Rodgers was 52
yards in the air on a dime in the back
of the endzone with like a 5 foot area
to hit with one leg where one leg with
not stepping into him he couldn't step
into it I mean first thing is if you're
gonna hurt a leg you'd rather hurt the
other one for a throw you don't want to
sit on your front leg and go you can
manipulate it a little bit better to
where yeah as you saw in the game he
couldn't step in two throws or when
you're throwing in that front foot you
rotate on that front foot I'm sure that
it was incredibly painful so he was
trying to keep that off the ground from
doing so he threw that just winging it
with one on one leg 52 yards in the 52
yard line I mean perfect then I was so
impressed with the throw to Davante
Adams yeah whistled by the defenders ear
it was like one of those classic Rogers
risers yeah comes out of nowhere through
it like sidearm even though I know and
then even the Randall Cobb play yeah
even all of that that's how bad that
offense is where the receivers run their
routes and no one's oh no one's open the
Randall Cobb play was awesome I don't
care what like people want to like oh so
what's the big deal it was a 12 yard
throw over the middle okay he again has
the wherewithal to know like man my legs
hurt but I'm gonna kind of hop out of
the pocket here and I'm still not gonna
panic in a huge situation on 3rd and 10
and to throw the ball across the
formation where the coverage was tight I
mean I can't remember those Eddie
Jackson
I think it's Eddie Jackson I mean that
have cleared his fingers by 4 inches I
mean it was just unbelievable and then
yes they got fortunate that
safety tried to cut off the cross or so
then copy catch it and nothing was there
but yes that goes down into the laurels
oh there he's unbelievable man and again
I I know we we just talk about him all
the time but no we have to hey I know
it's the greatest he's the greatest
performer I have ever seen he is the
greatest quarterback I've ever seen and
I you know he can he can do things that
really nobody in the sport has ever been
able to do we're gonna keep this going
let me just for everyone hi happy Monday
the NFL happened week onesie and all of
the teams played it was great we're
gonna recap our bets in a second I had
Sims do some deep dives he trying to
explain how did Ryan Fitzpatrick do that
yeah his dak Prescott bad and what
happened to Jimmy G so he went and watch
that film right and we're gonna do deep
dives on that for Simms so thank you for
doing that
and then also we're gonna look at what
do we get wrong what do we get right
share and dive into a little bit of
what's going on with levy on bail yeah
okay so we're gonna touch on all of that
today but I'm not done with Rogers yet
yeah as we are the Aaron Rodgers pocket
yes we are Peter King said it was the
best game of Aaron Rodgers life we are
very reactionary yeah Aaron Rodgers has
had some great game right does this
automatically get into that for you yeah
it is it is in the conversation I'm not
gonna say it's the greatest of all time
but damn it's it's up there and maybe I
need another day to think about it and
let it stew in my brain I mean he's had
so many unbelievable individual
performance I think that the Dallas
Cowboys divisional game in Dallas right
I mean I would argue the Superbowl he
won but that's the first nominal right
yes so that was unbelievable because I
thought the Arizona Cardinals game where
you had the that you have Mary's whisper
but those are great throws yes this is a
complete game complete and I guessed the
story of it might be the best one I
think it really often a cart coming back
looking at people and saying what's the
first thing you thought when you saw you
were down 20 to nothing and his answer
is 3 times 7 right I know I thought I
could give the team a jolt it's
hilarious because it's so funny he says
that thing but he does give a job I mean
you hear that there he this is where he
separates him
from everybody else again Brady's there
too yeah he is but not it's a different
circumstance I know what you're gonna
say you're gonna say which person when
they come on the field the rest of the
team goes we're gonna we're gonna win
because everybody else in New England
goes well at least we got Bella check
and everything else and he'll he'll
figure out some unbelievable game plans
here the coaching staff and Green Bay is
like oh I hope he comes back
oh my gosh I mean that's not what
happens again this is a six in 10
football team without Aaron Rodgers I'm
not trying to crap on Tom Brady here but
they're 14 and 6 without Tom Brady they
win three that they almost went three
quarters of their game when he's not
there
you know Cosmo tweeted this yes and it's
been everywhere and I want to say to the
dozens of people that have DM to me this
yeah believe me I was reading it no
matter what I quote Tom Brady once told
an NFL coach right if Aaron Rodgers had
Patriots offensive scheme and
institutional knowledge on opposing
defenses quote he'd throw for 7,000
yards every year he's so much more
talented than me period unquote
it is it we finally got it the quote
that we've been saying we are not saying
that Tom Brady is awesome
he's awesome but in comparison to Aaron
Rodgers physically it is not even close
nobody can compare to Aaron Rodgers I
mean how many times you how many Hall of
Fame quarterbacks have you met since
we've been working together the same the
same thing so again I know we seem like
we come over the top but I don't I if I
was like so dead wrong I think I'd admit
it at this point I'm that kind of guy
I'm willing to go there just because we
believe that one is better than two
doesn't mean we believe that two is bad
right
two is better than the thousands of
other quarterbacks that have all played
this game exactly right right now I mean
if you when Josh goes on Instagram and
let's say he's run the Sims Lefko
account and he goes Rodgers is the best
quarterback we get literally 200
comments saying that we hate Brady yeah
I not even relate it they're not it's
it's weird it's I hear that all the time
so you know me I have people that come
up to me like Brady's better and I'm
gonna be ok but yeah I mean that's very
interesting that he put that out I heard
that quote I have I know
you said things like that I know how
revered Aaron Rodgers is in that New
England building like when they've had
to prepare for him the year after I left
I believe they were alike oh my gosh I
mean it's just week what can we stop him
that's all it's about it's not like can
we stop this offense could wean us stop
this running game that everybody's plan
to buy Green Bay is how do we stop
number 12 that feeling them towards one
person was there ever another player
that you saw the Patriots organization
feel that way about I feel like the only
person I've heard Billy what Bill even
maybe on the defensive side of the ball
but only quarterback I remember I heard
Bill wax poetically about like that is
John Elway he was the only guy I've ever
heard where he just was like I mean
scheme could be perfect everything could
be perfect and he's just so great he can
overcome it and that's the same thing
with Rodgers yeah again it's not a knock
on Tom Brady he's in New England but I
you know I go back to the points of like
hey it's 32 completions in the Super
Bowl against your Eagles team 28 of
those throws he looked at the first guy
he was open and he threw it it's not
taking it away from great job he made
some great throws there is part of that
you know ability to anticipate the guy
being open but I didn't see an open
receiver at all that that's what I mean
Sunday that's what I mean so they're the
most open guy he threw all night was
when he hopped up in the pocket and
threw the ball the Davante Adams who
made the nice move and then ran in for
the touchdown
Devante times especially was special
he's like the perfect receiver for Roger
he really is he really is he's a great
round runner he can't fly but he's good
enough to beat you out the line of
scrimmage and he catches contested balls
almost always funny because his first
year we were worried about him no doubt
and all of a sudden he's an absolute dud
he is he's gonna have a very interesting
career arc at the end as he played
college whenever one thing I get I'm
sorry to cut you off I just have to get
this out of my head because I this is
the other thing I get about that
conversation all the time well I go
Rodgers the greatest of all time and
this is what people who defend Brady
well yeah physically he's the best of
all time and I want to pick what what
else is there there's nothing else what
what do you mean what else is there if
he's the best physically he's the best
he takes care of the ball because we're
talking about the Peyton Manning there I
enough I okay you
a field and all that Stu he does that's
you though he does it and he just
doesn't have the benefit of having the
offenses they've had you know that they
got to grow up in a different way drew
brees got Sean Payton to coddle him
Brady got Bill Belichick to coddle him
and bring him into this guy Manning is
the brain Peyton Manning is the brain
where he was actually like slash
offensive coordinator know this yes so
yeah there is he brings an element that
is different but I would also say that
that's an attribute it is it isn't
attribute there's no question you're
right and he's like Peyton's like he was
Johnny Unitas a guy that was kind of
ahead of the curve as far as the mental
aspect of the game but yeah it's cool to
hear Brady said that's what's cool about
Brady is he can I don't know if he said
that yesterday
yeah good he said at some point well I
mean yeah I mean yes I know all right so
I don't know yeah I always think hey
listen if Aaron Rodgers played on the
Patriots they would be eight no in Super
Bowls I mean I'm not trying to be a dick
come just telling you I think they'd be
eight no he's that special yeah it's not
really is yeah that's the reason why
when I have teams playing the Patriots I
go is their quarterback special enough
to ruin the great coaching yes right
that's why I was I going to show him
what yeah Russell Wilson does it we've
seen Cam Newton do it yeah you know
those are the guys who have winning
records against New England
I think Cam Newton's - no against New
England I think Russell Wilson's to win
one and they can do things you can't
coach err exactly and Aaron Rodgers want
to know meanwhile if Kyle fuller doesn't
drop that interception we're not talking
about this no we're not that data
interception where I look like what
Devante to hit his own pyre I hit a
defender when he fell down they collide
on imagine the other one I'll diva is
that first drive where they got the fuel
old he threw the seam down the middle
that was a dicey throat - I mean if they
get the interception there and get no
field goal I think it's gonna be too
much to overcome and they're gonna be
down 20 to nothing again the Bears gonna
have the ball once again so that was
amazing and do we want to talk about
yeah the other free show in that game
yeah one sack one interception one
touchdown one forced fumble one fumble
recovery and the hearts and minds of
everyone in Oakland losing their mind
because they realized that Jon Gruden in
an ego battle traded one of three
defensive players in the NFL that
single-handedly can destroy an office
Khaleel mac was amazing Kaleo Mac had
Bears fans thinking Super Bowl last
night first half of the game Matt Nagy's
offense looked dynamic special Allen
Robinson's going up and catching
floaters
I thought all-in-all Mitchell true
Biscay played well he did I thought even
more than that
Jordan Howard looks like a true feature
number one bag right now
tarik Cohen was all over the place but
Khalil Mac holy cow but this is the
first thing we have to just talk about
with him like he's been practicing for
six days total like he wasn't practicing
in Oakland so that's I mean that's where
I just think like my fans out there and
everyone's he can work out on his own
I'm sure he stayed in shape man there's
how different is it there's there's
nothing that can get you prepared for
that only the freakiest of the freaks
can pull that off and that's why we saw
Aaron Donald who had like eight days of
practice last year before he played in
the week two game and he came out that's
such a rare breed of person there's only
a few guys in the sport where I could
say they can go all training camp and
then come out in the game and still be
the best player on the field at their
position yeah that was unbelievable what
he did I mean it really was it was he is
such a freak show and so many different
ways about him because I think sometimes
pass rushers get put into a box
yeah like Vaughn had a good day
yesterday but what was it what is it
about his skillset that's so special he
had for his size he has an incredible
power his power is much smaller like
yeah he's went six to trick a three to
55 to 58 right that's around yes
remember when Von Miller had the pass
rushing Summa and he was like that in
sidearm move you do Khalil he's like I
can't do that like you can do that I
can't nobody can do that except like
Reggie white where you can be like from
the left end position rush and throw
your right arm up underneath a 325 pound
tackle and throw him out of the way and
then undercut him to the quarterback so
that's what gets player search because
they're all bracing for the power right
they're all going
oh gosh if he bulled rushing me I'm
going back into the quarterback so they
get ready for that and then he's got
good quickness he's got good hand
yeah and he has enough speed and
shoulder dip to also threaten you with
that
that's not his greatest thing yeah as
far as speed around the edge but he can
dip either way who has her the power him
or Donald Donald yeah Donald's just a
different guy but he's got more power
than von yes like any of the power
rushers I would put like I mean any of
the guys on the edge yeah like true pass
rushers like who we gonna say Everson
grip Oh
Vaughn ruler both yeah I don't think any
of them can mess with his power Wow I
don't his power is spent know what he
does yeah he kind of is you know they
always used to talk about like Bill
Russell when he'd block a shot he keep
it in balance right when Khalil max acts
he's trying to take the ball Oh ever he
doesn't just smack it out like he did
against our guide to Shawn Kaiser he
went and said no mine he did it out of
your hand I'm gonna rip the necklace off
your face and look at his body I mean
he's all legs but in arms and a neck I
mean it's just he is just naming body I
believe because these ankles he's got
nice feet he's an earlobe he's unreal he
was put on earth to play that position
and that was really awesome only thing
that hurt him last night he ran out of
gas he ran into gas and then because
Rodgers was playing on one league leg
Rodgers made a very conscious effort to
get the ball of his hand quickly to
which negated some of his abraded
against the text exactly all right uh
it's crazy though you're watching Sunday
Night Football and one of the most
talked-about guys during the entire game
was Jon Gruden yeah everyone's talking
what an idiot
I can't believe he did this and if they
get off to a bad start
so we recording this on Monday so if the
Raiders get off to a bad start and
they're down 14 nothing to the Rams oh
my gosh that place is gonna be the boo
birds will be as loud as they've ever
been because they just got a reminder
like if I was a Raiders fan that made it
worse yeah it definitely made it worse
Jon Gruden was I promise you Jon Gruden
wasn't in his hotel room going oh man
did this really have to happen I mean he
was probably like gosh damn I mean
that's not a good one thing that John
was sitting there in a way going man I
hope the Packers beat them up yeah
definitely I hope he's I hope he's not
like kind of non-existent tonight for
him to go out that way just makes the
whole organization look bad and of
course you had the fan base like you
said it's already mad at
out it and this just fuels the fire how
do you think does Groot have to address
it in the locker room no not anymore he
probably already did he's probably
already addressed it in a team meeting
like last week when they made the trade
and tried to give his two cents of why
it had to be done
so yeah that'll be that'll be
interesting do you think that Khalil
Mack destroying the Packers last night
impacts the Raiders on Monday Night
Football do you think that the team was
watching the game last night and going
yes yeah I mean when you're playing like
at a game like that where they don't
have to be up early in the morning like
guys are in their hotel room watching
the games and kahlil's their guy I mean
we've been out there and I've been out
there a few other times too I mean he
was loved he's he's such a good dude and
he talks like this to remember we were
like super quiet yeah we were like are
you serious could he speak up you big
freaking freak of nature killer so yes
they were all watching and I'm sure
Bruce Irvin was sitting over there going
like how did we trade him away what the
hell were we thinking yeah it's it's
unbelievable man is right but at the
same point I could still see the Bears
having a monster year there's like a
really good team bears really good team
and the last thing about this game is
very hard to have the same sort of
aggressiveness when you're up 20 to
nothing going to the half
it really is there's something to be
said about that I know people sometimes
go like oh how could they blow that lead
well hey it's not easy Aaron Rodgers was
special we know all that but the offense
did kids get conservative there's no
question I mean there was a there was a
thing there I mean we saw all these
different formations and schemes and
everything in the first half the second
half it became alright let's just
execute our basic stuff yeah we should
be able to pull it out and they lost
their momentum and then they tried to
put the pedal to the metal again and you
couldn't do it yeah I just felt like
they should have just give them all to
Jordan Howard every time I feel like
every time we touched it he was going
the third and one call deserves to be
second-guessed that was the tight end
screen well that was the that was the
one where Collinsworth pointed out about
the kid 93 Gilbert taking up Cohn on the
wheel route first of all he should have
thrown that ball that would have been a
touchdown if he throws that ball
accurately he had him but they ran the
ball down the field the whole time and
then all of a sudden tried to throw it
on third
it's no reason to be cute no reason to
be curious ah quick little Sims and left
go fantasy league update Sims yeah
we're currently up 5.4 points over
Linville lamb chops
he has Matt Prater so if you're
listening to the podcast
hopefully Matt Prater missed a lot of
field goals on Monday Night Football
we're up five point for our big day Jake
Chris Thompson was on the bench for 21.8
points it's okay
he will not be on the bench anymore yeah
he looked him amazing Chris Thompson for
Washington so Alex Smith's number number
one a number two receivers yesterday my
mind were Jordan Reed and Chris Thompson
and Alex Smith looked really good he did
look really good they were it's just a
good offense for him because it's all
these underneath guys with the
occasional Paul Richardson exactly right
it is it's a little it's Andy Reid ish
that's what they'll do and Jon Gruden
just like Andy Reid a lot of times it's
gonna go hey just be consistent here Jay
Gruen I think I called him John you did
but he will he will draw up two or three
plays every week to go
we got him but we got him right here so
when I call this play be ready and and
that's fits perfectly to what he does
Aaron Gibbons hit us up on social I
believe his fantasy team is Phil Miller
ice which is your guy he said I think I
have the closest match up in the SL FL
he's currently leading Billy Manziel
it's actually over neither of them any
players left 117 point six to 117 point
to he's and what sucks for Billy Manziel
yeah he started the Chargers defense and
it got him negative three welcome to
fantasy I'm sure Andrew sure will have a
youtube coming out later for us anybody
else receivers did well yeah Adam
Thielen Rydell juju all did good yeah
but Jimmy didn't do great and you're a
betting show recap what do you think oh
we wait for the betting show I mean this
no just just to kind of go over our
records before Monday night there was
there's been 14 games how do you think
your record is just against the spread
just my record was not good because I
feel like all my $10 but I'm gonna say
so that was 16 games I'm gonna say we
had 14 Oh 14 sorry I'm gonna say I was 4
and 10 you were 7 and 7 Oh
okay you are currently standing at minus
100 only minus 100 because you got 500
on the Bears and you have $10 on the
Jets and $10 on the Rams Jets plus six
and a half Rams plus four grams minus
four and a half right eye on Sunday went
ten and four and I am currently up $700
Josh I'm 800 in the hole already I have
a hundred on the Jets and I have a
hundred on the RAM so you can swell up
to 900 or it could fall down to five I
realized 700 ear formulas up seven
hundred one week is probably the best
I've ever I got to start stealing from
you if you're gonna steal from me all
the time I gotta steal from you don't
you steal from me in Week one what what
did I do this week you spread your money
out evenly I did yeah and I did idiot
things like look is he Russell Wilson on
the road in Denver yeah yeah meanwhile
so now Denver I bet on [ __ ] Dan Quinn
and Steve Sarkisian what the hell was I
thinking wow those are the some of the
ones I I what what the hell was that I
don't know those are some of the things
when I had a goes yeah every time he's
about to call a play this ghost comes
mine when ghost would run in a spread
formation to Tevin Coleman even though
it's working every time you do
everybody said Julio Jones doesn't get
the ball so just throw no no matter why
first try go into a bunch go into goal
line and don't put in Julio and then
only throw to him later in the game ah
that's what I was mad about I think your
other thing was that you the Chargers
oh you put the bet and then Bosa didn't
play right that hurt but yeah I have a
statistic here good Andy Reid when he
has more than seven days to prepare his
team averages 27 point one points per
game in all other games his team's
average twenty three point nine man that
has more than three points different
between when he has that's how much he
can scheme up three points no other
coach can do that no he's I mean he's
unreal he really is that that man
they're so fun to watch we're gonna get
it yeah okay let you read eat you under
your deep dives first I want to do it
let's do what we got right what we got
wrong okay so let's do what we got wrong
right
you got it Lana wrong yeah I got it
right first thing with Philadelphia
their defensive line looked phenomenal
yeah one thing that I love that they do
which you talk about Mac slowing down
right they'll play a lot of Derek
Barnett and destiny vaio and stuff in
the first quarter so that at the end of
the game it's Brandon Graham Fletcher
Cox Chris Long and Michael Bennett and
they're ready to go
Fletcher Cox I know was one of the most
dumped he what a way to start at the
play up with him just like they couldn't
do anything
but my question for you yes and I'll
watch that film I can I was mad I didn't
get to that this weekend before Sunday
and again Wednesday we're gonna do our
deep film yeah but who was worse Matt
Ryan or Steve Sarkisian oh because Matt
looked really bad yeah no stars
Sarkisian it's very basic there's no
doubt about it I have certain big-time
concerns about them I in fact I'm almost
willing to say that Atlanta has no
chance of making the playoffs I'll be
out for the season which as soon as
Canada went down you texted me and Josh
and when that's bad and if he's out
there seasons done I mean he's he that
much of a game change he really is
especially for that scheme again it's
he's playing that camp Chancellor
position and he's special I mean he's
one of the best and football it's like
having a linebacker down there in the
run game and yet oh it's a pass and he
can cover as good as any strong safety
in the sport so it really will hurt them
and Dion Jones is how the foot knight so
there you got that or you'll be right
now after what you saw against
Philadelphia and with Keon O'Neal going
down yeah you're saying the Falcons are
done after week one I am they're gonna
have to prove it to me until they get
back into it I have nothing to take away
from that game so to get back to the
Sarkisian thing to where it's yeah it's
certainly concerning okay it's just lack
of imagination especially in the red
zone you saw the end of the game I mean
just run straight and that was the game
plan run straight and we'll throw it but
then the other thing everybody out there
from Atlanta and thinks I'm a Matt Ryan
hater not a Matt Ryan hater but reality
hurts sometimes everybody he got he's
gonna get exposed this year he's going
to get exposed because he
just not that special of a quarterback
he's really good he's top ten he's top
12 he's somewhere between eight and
fourteen sure we can argue about where
he is there but if somebody comes up to
me and tries to tell me Matt Ryan's a
top five or top six quarterback just be
quiet and walk away because I don't want
to hear it
he's can do a lot of things well but he
is not capable of making game-changing
throws or game-changing plays with his
legs and that was that was a bad
performance I don't know what other way
to say it I mean what can you look at at
that game and go oh yeah that he's
special no it's just it's just not that
way
júlio special Julio is special right and
but when that's probably why Julio was
upset we know it's wrong signed a
hundred million dollar deal and julio
said i need more money we know it's why
I know that's why what I've been around
so many people that have been around
Julio and Atlanta and I just know that's
the reason I will say if they ended up
calling that 52 yard or a catch it's a
whole nother game yes the refs hashtag
keep it in your pants that was that game
that was that was a catch that was
stupid I think you don't think it was I
think at the very end he put his other
hand on it cuz I think Jalen Mills
kicked it right and I was like ooh I
don't freakin that's righteous I know
it's really close but again I know we
always sound like we're a Matt Ryan
hater but to uh Doug Peterson yeah
calling not Philly Philly but call it
well it was called Philly Philly not
feeling special calling what the
Patriots ran with Tom Brady that play
call we've always talked about coaches
having guts yeah and not shrinking in
the moment I was so wrong about Doug
Peterson do you remember how hard I was
on Doug Peters I do yes I am surely last
year happy yeah and the year before yeah
oh there was some moments that deserved
a little criticism was I don't think
there's an alibi two years ago yeah yeah
I think we saw the turnaround last year
early on I will always look at that
Carolina game when they played on
Thursday night Thursday night and I
could just tell that you let him have
the game of his life right and I could
just tell the team loved Doug Peterson
the way they supported him was some of
the going for it on fourth downs and
things like that I I just
remember thinking like wow like Philly
might have something special here like
they really love this coach their mom
lion Hassan if they had to buy the next
week too and then came out against
Denver and kept and just killed him and
that's really when the train started yes
and then Jaya Jaya got around there same
time other thing that we really good a
Jaya Jaya did look around like he from
London yeah well you know I think it's
called the Simza left go bump you come
on the podcast you play a little bit
well right I was wrong about the Giants
I had the Giants keeping it close I mean
the defense they did all they really
needed to do I thought they kept
Jacksonville in check that's really the
Jacksonville Jaguars that's what scares
me
yeah you're destroying a team sake one
bus off an incredible 62 run you're
sitting there going we might lose this
game now that's what's wrong with the
Jaguar yes but how was Eli and how was
the and was the offensive line as bad as
people are making it seem well the I
mean that is a Jaguar that defensive
line is gonna make almost every
offensive line in football look somewhat
like that yeah it wasn't it wasn't great
there was certainly Eli was under duress
you know I made some good plays there's
no question about it but there's also
like four or five plays where I go damn
if he hits that they're gonna win the
game I mean he he bought two throws to
Odell have 14 points on the board there
for sure right the one where he's in the
inside crosser rolling across the field
he threw it out of bounds and then there
was the other like the post right down
the middle I think Odell had a clear
stuff I mean he was gone and you know
you just you just gotta throw it out
there and he's got to throw it with a
little more arcing pace as we would say
in the NFL but do you leave since it is
the Jaguars going okay maybe they got
something here because that was the most
open I've seen Odell in a very long time
III liked what I saw from the Giants I'm
not discouraged by it at all I'm really
not it's a different team we saw out
there there was people open there was
definitely run game things that I liked
I mean the scheme this scheme was not
the issue in that game I mean it was
Nate's older Eric flowers will Hernandez
had moments of getting their ass whooped
it looked like on TV and I'll do my deep
dive when I watch billows DeMarcus
Campbell Yannick and gawk way Marcell
Darius like yeah I think people are
being a little too harsh on the Giants
of the meet I mean I got in here today
and people were like oh look like
McAdoo 2.0 and I wanted to make what I
mean we're the hardest part about our
job you know watching the same game then
I don't know I don't know what else to
say yeah look at the final score and
they go
you didn't even get 20 right [ __ ]
miles check miles jack I mean you saw
that there the prick they get a seven
points from their defense but the Giants
have two of the freakiest people in the
sport on the offensive side of the ball
I've never seen anybody do that what's a
Quon did to them you've never seen
anyone do to the jaguars then synchron
awesome it'll bounce it outside turn the
corner on the Jacksonville Jaguars and
run for a 60 HR touchdown tell me who's
done that that we can remember in the
last two years I don't remember anybody
like that girly-girly to catch a screen
for a long one I feel like he had a long
one maybe he had one long run I mean he
couldn't have anything on a pass game
but maybe he did I can go back yeah but
but you're right I haven't seen turned
the corner and go to the house on
Jacksonville in the run game I mean they
they got so many freaks of nature on
that defense it just doesn't happen
Derrick Henry Derrick Henry did have a
few freaky runs you're right he did he's
probably the only guy I can't think of
anybody else off the top of my head but
it's that type of player it's a girlie
it's a say quad Berkeley that's good
only I mean dress them I will say this
just from an opponent of the Giants as
an Eagles fan yeah the fact that Odell
leaves the game with a hundred and
eleven yards and say Kwan leaves the
game with over a hundred yards against
the Jaguars I know that I'm gonna be
loading up on the Giants the next few
weeks especially next week I don't know
what the line is right now I don't want
to look at the line for Cowboys but as
bad as the Cowboys looked I thought the
Giants actually looked pretty darn high
and I really felt I mean think about the
things their defense held strong I mean
their defense over that points for that
did nothing bortles got all his little
cheap completions sheet little Slayer
the boots and screen champions of the
world yeah I mean that's all it is you
got to stop that and then they're gonna
throw a fade down the sidelines but the
Giants - how could you not be encouraged
with a UI Apple Eli Apple was phenomenal
in the game yesterday they put him on
our island a number of times and he made
plays so that was encouraging from the
Giants aspect point of view as well yeah
and yeah I think the Giant
sir a good football team I mean this is
not gonna be an easy schedule for them
here but they're dangerous think about
Evan Engram going up and catching the
ball for jinx and Eric flowers favorite
number away big plays they got called
back exactly of some improv right think
about Odell's gonna catch the shallow
cross route and Eli doesn't throw it out
in front of him I mean he's gonna run
for 25 30 more yards there just a few
situations there where yeah everything
counts against Jacksonville
Jacksonville's that special again
Jacksonville you could argue is the best
in football at all three levels
Jacksonville's so good that they line up
in the same two defenses in ball game
and say screw you you know what we're
gonna do try to come at us suck that
ended on a muffed punt oh I know that
really did I wanted to see that I wanted
to see because Odell was drawing pass
interference as the entire game now
there should have been a pass
interference on the fourth down before
that no doubt about it
yeah I think the Giants kind of got a
little screwed in that one you were
wrong about the Seahawks where are you
at them right now I was expecting more
to their offensive line I'll say that
trying to watch those you know 4 or 4
o'clock games yeah I mean you know I
just wasn't at all impressed with the
run game like I thought I would be
within within the preseason that never
got going that's how I am Suffolk and
past protection was an issue right
surprised I mean how do you not have
more of a game plan for the first game
of the year on the road to negate a
Vaughn negated him a little bit you
can't just let him go one-on-one with
Jermaine a Fetty so I said Coolio Mac
Von Miller finished with three sacks two
forced fumble and a fumble recovered
gosh I mean he's just he's lightning
he's he's the one of the most just
straight ahead explosive people I've
ever seen in the sport coming off yeah
who else was straight ahead explosive
what person Phillip Lindsey Oh 15
touches 71 rushing 31 receiving and a
touchdown and all the talks been about
Royce Freeman Phillip Lindsey was the
most impressive running back
good job by you thanks man he looked and
he's got the hair and he's got a spark
to him he does he's got a I mean he's
got the rocket up his ass I mean it's
it's three steps and he's full speed
there's a reason about Davis is letting
him wear third no doubt I mean he's got
an inkling like they would
let's um slappy call Terrell Davis like
hey our third string running back was to
wear this no I'm sure the owner and the
coach were all like hey this kids kind
of special and he's got to see him in
person and knows that and guys before
you go ooh this is Denver's season since
1989 in the first two weeks of the year
when Denver has a home game they're now
32 and 3 right 32 amazing and three it's
a it's a remember remember where they
did to Dallas last year they like beat
him up by like 40 we did it to the
Eagles a few years ago there's a lot of
very good teams that go into Denver and
because they're not in shape and they're
playing at a high altitude and it's
warmer and then that it's ever gonna be
in it loud as hell there and it's loud
as hell that Denver steals wins yeah so
I'm gonna say that the Seahawks are not
that bad right and I'm also gonna say
that Denver is not that good and I know
that Seattle wasn't that great but brain
and Marshall looked good he did Tyler
Lockett had a big play definitely Earl
Thomas gets a pick right away right
I think the Seahawks are going to be
fine I do too
I'm not like going oh I'm abandoning
ship I think the Seahawks are to be in
this conversation Barry what were you
doing right to not protect Russ right
and other thing too in that game we
Roy's Freeman fumbling and I don't know
the context of how it happened yet I
don't remember
Roy's Freeman fumbled the football and
Pete Carroll couldn't find his red flag
do you know that happened in the game
key Jeff Fischer des he could not find
his red flag and it was a clear fumble
and Denver got to keep the ball Seattle
had recovered it how do you I don't even
know how that happens you're a head
coach you only have like five things to
worry about on game day manage the clock
go for it kick the field goal
hey let's run the fake here if you're
Pete Carroll chew gum right clap Allah
where's my trident but yeah it's just I
delicious how does that happen I don't
know how that happens he throws like
something on the field - hey were like
it does he didn't yeah and they were
like no it's not the red flag Wow I know
I saw again those are things I'll hit on
and on on the Wednesday podcast out for
Thursday morning last thing we got wrong
that was notable both got the Chargers
wrong neither of us knew that Joey Bosa
was gonna miss that game they had a lot
of injuries to be honest we talked about
Andy Reed Patrick mahomes
gets the ball too
wide receivers at such a quick speed
that we're gonna see so much yak
yeah the Chiefs right he sets up Tyree
kill to go on those runs right because
Tyrese getting it faster than he's ever
gotten it and when he gets it it's over
he doesn't have to break stride it's
incredible are we ready to have this
convo now is Tyree kill a top receiver
in the NFL I want to do it like this
yeah let me go let me go here's how I'm
gonna do this fantasy but I'm glad what
you said about my Holmes right about
this yeah I mean those are things that
like go overlooked right it's just
because the this the receivers want the
ball on them quick you know they don't
want to sit there and wait and go oh
during when James is coming to kill me
here they wanted so they can react and
make a move the the slant he threw to
Tyree kill for the touchdown first of
all he threw it like sidearm and got it
out of his hand so quick and then with
the pace on the football I mean the
defense doesn't have a time to react and
really close in on him and then he
throws it accurately like you're saying
and hey most fast people have a rocket
up their ass in the NFL Tyree got two of
them I'm just is I've never seen
anything like it
so according to this fantasy football
it's called a D piece and I'll get an
average draft position I think I think
that's what it means but these are where
guys are typically getting drafted I
want to know if Tyreke Hill should be
moved up he is currently the 10th best
wide receiver draft that's insane is he
a better wide receiver is Tyreke ill a
better wide receiver than Mike Evans yes
I'm gonna take him over Mike Evans yes I
mean if you add me and go okay you could
pick one of the two and Evans is awesome
because his size and speed combo is
special but I would go no I'd I'd rather
have Tyree killed right now is Tyree
kill better than AJ Green I think so and
AJ Green's amazing I know I I did one of
my pft drafts in the summer with Florio
and I took him over AJ Green I'd like
who that is
but you took you think that Tyree Hills
better than AJ Green I do
damn yeah I think you have to take we
gotta take into account what he doesn't
returning the football you know I think
that's the other ass everyone I think
when it comes to wide receiver goes but
if I lob it up age
Green's gonna come down with it I mean
Tyree killed went up against the
Chargers and came yeah it's not gay yeah
AJ greens gonna come up with more of
those than Atari kill but is AJ Green
gonna catch the six yard slant and go
sixty yards every time like Tyree killed
us
No Tyreke hill or Davante Adams Tyree
kill not even close not even close
Tyree kill or Keenan Allen stop this and
just get into it's Tyree kill deserves
to be in the conversation with Odell
Beckham jr. Julio Jones Antonio Brown
and you know let's say AJ Green and him
Michael Thomas Keenan Allen oh no so you
think that Tyreke Hill in your mind is
definitely top five yes
Odell DeAndre Hopkins Antonio Brown
Julio Tyree kill is he five I think I
would take AJ over DeAndre Hopkins so I
would make him and I would I would get
DeAndre out of it and not like DeAndre
but you know my thoughts about him his
ability to do things after the catch is
not up to par with those guys so Tyree
kill compared to a B Odell and Julio
he's more like an a/b or obj right he's
that kind of guy I don't think he's
quite the nuanced route runner Antonio
Brown or Odell Beckham jr. are those two
things that I think get lost in the
shuffle with on Odell and Antonio
they're really good route runners and
they understand not only like they can
physically do it they understand how to
set people up just so they're nuanced
there right so ty reeks just gonna be
I'm faster than exactly right he's not
the greatest route runner but Tyree kill
can do things that neither one of them
can do - I mean Odell Beckham jr. is up
there with one of the most explosive
people I've ever seen he's not as
explosive as Tyree kill I would argue
that Tyree kill straightaway speed is in
the conversation with Deion Sanders bo
Jackson Terrell Green right it's like
top fastest people we've ever seen in
the sport there's nobody that can go
zero to 60 what's his status 60 yard
plus touchdowns like the most ever it's
the most ever that's what I mean these
guys went playing a football for three
years
so what's here's the thing - for people
that just started listening to Sims
enough for watching Sims and left go you
are on Tyreke L on the preseason of his
work
year yeah you were on Tyree kill when he
was a running back that's what people
forget he started as a running back and
busted out a 70 yard run I think it was
against the Titans and he went he should
be the starting running back every time
over Spencer where and now he's turned
into this jack-of-all-trades and to
combine him with Patrick mahomes and to
Travis Kelce only had one catch yeah but
with Travis Kelce Andy Reid if you know
Andy Reid he loves running backs and
tight ends in the past game more than
anything in Philadelphia it was Brian
Westbrook and he drafted LJ Smith in the
second year right and they each had
their own part of the playbook of their
own special place no doubt that's his
Chad Lewis he had Chad Lewis for a long
time in Philadelphia goes to Kansas City
he's had Travis Cal he loves that deep
right shark and request I want him in
the backfield to have this trio Patrick
mahomes Travis Kelce Tyree kill I think
it's the best Andy Reid trio he's ever
had and with the ability to have a Sammy
Watkins that can go deep every now and
then was he out there yesterday I don't
I know but that's what's amazing this is
a dynamic core dynamic core and an India
thing but Tyreke LLL still think their
defense stinks yeah it's got big
questions I mean we saw them as chargers
really could do whatever they wanted I
mean props Travis Benjamin dropped Ryan
probably dropped like - yeah who was the
other one there was another long pass
that was dropped in Cairo Willie I
really I mean like that was an egregious
trite that was a touchdown yes and
Benjamin's was at least gonna put them
in feel well position yes and he breaks
the tackle he's in a score the other
thing Tyreke kills going to do
frustrating they are frustrating I don't
want to bet on them all year I have no
idea what they're gonna do
it's unbelievable but the Tyree killed
thing - is the he's the greatest decoy
there is - oh he's the kind of guy
that's we're gonna he runs on lorna's
fake reverse row beam hunt oh by the way
they have cream on I know they're right
there it was unreal one of the best
throws of the day by mahomes - was the
throat of the fullback out of the
backfield the wheel route thought
laughter man holy cow
I mean that was a really gifted throw
and I'll say the other thing I like that
Andy did I liked an andy game
two other cheap touchdowns that's what
you do to build confidence of a young
quarterback yeah he shuffled the ball
one foot in front of him one time is the
Anthony Thomas the other time it was
Tyree kill but they're good things to
how he had a four touchdown game right
here's our quarterback he's he's hitting
on all set so mahomes who's gonna leave
that game feeling good about himself
he left him but going okay I can play in
this league and make plays and I feel
really good about myself two other guys
that I'm just gonna mention guys you got
wrong yeah Denzel Ward two interceptions
yeah hey these showed me that he might
be the best corner in the draft right
not bad yeah he was good all preseason
you've always said that Denzel Ward is
gonna cover guys great you just didn't
know if I was gonna make plays exactly
made some plays made some place and San
Francisco 49ers fans were mad at you
DeForest Buckner had two and a half
sacks and you called him a non sack just
kind of stand-up guy to him sorry so for
also for all the San Francisco Twitter
people that think that you run the Sims
and left go Twitter account because I
think a lot of people do they see Sims
to have sex yeah I also thought that
Warner kid played really well for San
Francisco like I didn't watch that side
of the ball yet you know I only watch
the often every time I looked up he was
knocking Dalvin cook I mean their
defense has to feel good about
themselves they only let up 17 points in
the game I mean let's stop Jimmy G threw
a pick six yeah that was seven of the
points that's my concern about their
soda right Minnesota and again I you
know about Buckner I know so Buckner
Buckner yeah I don't think he's a sack
master it doesn't mean I don't think
he's a good player uh also I think we
have to take into account what's the
weakness of the offensive line yeah I
mean Minnesota's all line is not special
right now they're beat up especially in
the middle so for anybody out there that
thought I was just totally hating under
Forrest I'm not I mean I'd love to have
DeForest on my Deva it's a line I'm just
saying I don't think he's gonna be able
to apply that consistent pressure all
game long the all year long the other
defensive baller that we didn't get to
yet yeah TJ watt Oh
four sacks holy a field goal block to
taught to like seal the tie sit in
sideways with five different Z's asked
me on the DMS I'm going to ask you is JJ
Watt still
the best football player in his family
TJ watt for sacs in a field goal block
against the Browns who's the better
football player the wot family right now
it's close its close I be I will be
really interested to evaluate like but
there were some moments in the game
yesterday where I was like where is JJ
Watt where is Jadeveon Clowney well
Brady takes like three second I know I
know and then but as the game went on I
did start to see JJ slip through the
line a lot and do little things like
that so let me let me let me evaluate
JJ's game first before we go back into
it I'm not gonna say he's better than JJ
yeah I'm looking for takes I will say
he's better than I ever thought he would
be
I really he really is when he came out
in the draft I didn't think he was a
first-round pick I thought he was like
top 50 pick that's what I kind of looked
at him as I just said I don't know if
he's quite explosive enough to get
around the edge and a regular basis but
he has a complete football game again
where there's nothing I watch them on
film or a TV where I go he's amazing at
this but I look at him ago there's no
weakness
he has no bad spot at his game I mean
every time Roxanna coverage is good
every time I looked up he was destroying
someone right Steelers defense to look
good the Steelers the is real all right
so things that we did get right is gonna
leave us into one of your deep dives the
Buccaneers yeah both call that thing
love it by the way looking ahead
remember Saints have started at least
Owen to the last four years and they
have the Browns at home this week right
I am very tempted to go Browns
well what does it mean the spread or
just the game itself kind of both it'll
be it'll be tough right I really mean
we'll break it down yesterday you know
Orleans is going to have to go back to
the drawing board on what they've done
on defense but the main thing is before
we get to your deep dive on Ryan
Fitzpatrick yeah are we concerned about
the Saints defense they love five
hundred and twenty nine total yards 417
passing yards and only one punt honestly
let's get right to Fitzpatrick because I
think it's gonna touch on the same yeah
go ahead you started off with what jump
right so I'm gonna look through your
notes I already have but I'm gonna I
kind of want you to go deep into it
the first thing I'd like you to do
I starred one thing on the left so if
you could read what I starred please
read that uh oh that isn't such a nice
star by you thank you
hashtag or Fitz throwing it as good as I
have ever seen and when lanes open up he
didn't think twice
he just ran so overall yeah it was your
overall take away from Ryan Fitzpatrick
people are going nuts other people are
going this is going to fade soon other
people are saying it might not be Jameis
as job when he gets back when you
finished watching the film where did you
stay well if they go to it if they went
to at a3 Jameis is not gonna get the job
his first week back which I also believe
is a short week against the Bears on a
Thursday night but there's no way
there's no way that's that offense was
playing at a very high level there I
would say this first of all Fitzpatrick
threw the ball as good as I've ever seen
him throw the ball okay
second thing is like I said with the
running he was just very smart he didn't
like sit back in the pockets they tried
to play like what would I would call to
Tampa to spy where they'd drop a D
tackle out and then play Tampa too so
they have eight guys back in coverage
and three rushing when he just saw the
lane wide open and the spy guy moved one
way he just took off okay six yards hey
it's second and four have fun defending
that right second of four the run games
their screens are there play-action
passes there whatever you want is there
they not attack Fitz pass I don't know
this is my number one thing with them
first of all is and them you mean the
Saints is that we've said this before in
years past Brian Fitzpatrick he's
usually at his worst when you keep him
in the pocket he likes to run I know he
looks like white guy unathletic person
which he's not the most athletic guy in
the world but he's athletic enough to go
get first downs on third and five and
third and six so they let him do that I
think one too many times
extremely disappointed in the Saints t
line the Saints T line got abused
I mean abuse Wow yeah I a Bucs whole
line that's not supposed to be that
right I mean it's it's unproven to say
anything and the big thing is early on
the Bucs had a little success in the run
game that kind of stopped but the Bucs
that were like why would we run when
we're throwing the ball like this I was
disappointed with just the inability
even really get pressure on him and then
really the Saints gave up too they just
sided said hell we won't even try to get
pressure we're just gonna rush for or
rush three and see if we can confuse
them but you wrote down that that the
Saints didn't get a tackle for loss
until four minutes left in the third
quarter yes and a camera who was it on
that play where did I write that but I
know it was extremely unimpressive by
their front seven uh you also wrote down
Evans was a lot better than Marcus
Lattimore B Oh Marcus Lattimore Marshawn
he whooped the crap out of them Wow and
this is a Marshall a lot more that you
have is top five yeah I mean and that'll
make me really going into this year but
yes I mean and there's what's more
concerning to me is not only that that
Evans goes for seven for 147 they're
really the concerning thing to me is
there was about two other times where I
said if Ryan Fitzpatrick went to Evans
that would have been another 50-yard
touchdown like he ran by them and then I
don't know when New England thought ken
Crowley was Darrell renew Orleans New
Orleans I don't know when they thought
like will put Ken Crowley on an island
against the Shawn Jackson and he'll be
okay I just don't understand the process
so first of all let's just talk about
the first touchdown of the game
you said it was a coverage missed under
the coverage mistake I believe it was I
the Saints but by the Saints and I
believe it was covered three where
everyone's gonna see number 43 Marcus
Robinson chasin after DeSean Jackson and
think it's it has nothing to do with him
he he was just chasing the real thing is
it's covered three and I believe Ken
Crawley took the out route and he
shouldn't take out route he's the cover
yeah he's covered through he's got to
play his third there was a guy
underneath him and Patrick Robinson that
was there to take away the out route so
he took the bait he came up and now the
now DeSean ran a post corner basically
you wrote so many notes
they attacked Crowley consist
consistently they they felt very
confident in that matchup no matter who
it was Chris Godwin DeSean Jackson Evans
if they went one-on-one they had no fear
of sowing the preseason you like to look
a crowd I did I've always liked the look
of Crowley but you know even when he
covered well he couldn't make a play on
the ball I mean you saw like the Godwin
really awesome catch in the end zone yes
I mean he was all over him
just gonna make a pie on the ball and
you said New Orleans play too much man a
man and no one should play man a man
that much against the Bucs nobody with
guys like Evans to Sean and OJ Howard
right they're just too hard to match up
I mean Demario davis is covering OJ
Howard one-on-one if I was a quarterback
I'd be like oh my gosh this is amazing
you mean their run stopping middle
linebackers gonna cover our four five
tight end like yes that I mean that
would have been number one thing to me
would have been let's be multiple in our
coverages and see if we can confuse them
and not give them the opportunity to
throw one-on-one balls up down the field
from what you've seen
we know that fits this happens a lot
it's a cycle of fits patch right he
comes in he surprises us he outperforms
you pay him and then he becomes a dud
right what is your forecast they play
Philadelphia next week do they play
Pittsburgh the week after that and then
Chicago so defense defense defense he
was this a flash in the pan or could you
see this lasting for a little bit longer
if they can they schematically will be
annoying for Jim Schwartz to prepare for
this week cuz Jim likes to play
man-to-man he's not afraid of it they
played a lot of zone though they did
they did they played more zone they
certainly didn't this because Weiland
Mills bites on everything a little bit
so I will be interested to see what they
do there and if they can protect you
know I mean Connor is a good play caller
well that's the thing the Eagles d-line
might get enough pressure by that's the
difference I was very disappointed with
the Saints D line in general and yeah
not even our man cam Jordan had a good
game he just never really popped nobody
on their front seven pop they need to
get Marcus Davenport into that
conversation more more and more let me
just see if there's anything else here
Bucs across the board when I want eight
for 13 on third downs I mean that's
unbelievable you know third so all of
this domination the games forty eight to
forty with three minutes left its third
and 11 and Ryan Fitzpatrick after rush
takes the ball puts it under his arm
runs forward and like run
through a defender and gets the first
down on the third 11 - ice the game but
like the lane integrity by the Saints T
line sometimes they would literally get
mosh down to one area and they're like
all four of them are in the same gap and
now he could either just shuffle and
have nobody in front him to throw the
football or he tucked it and ran yeah
that's what he did that's the other
thing about this game is no one's
talking about the fact that the Bucks
looked completely helpless and let up 41
points on defense yes that's the side of
the game let's not forget right Gil
Isley fumbles yes they were driving and
Michael Thomas fumbled in the middle of
the field like I kept just going this I
mean the Bucks look good but they're not
gonna win this they're not gonna win
this like the Saints aren't gonna stop I
mean the Saints are the kings of this
sign it kind of game like oh you want to
play 51 48 great alright oh I don't
think I missed anything else there did I
all right I want to talk dak Prescott
okay a lot of people are coming for Dax
neck right now a lot of people are
including Dez never came for deck yeah
but he was tweeting things like it's
kind of cool calling out all the signals
and knowing which route players are
about to run yeah he tweeted that out
but first and foremost before we get
into a conversation about the Cowboys
offense the lack of weapons at receiver
the simplicity of Scott Linehan and his
inability to advance the offensive line
not being as good as we thought the ball
coming off of Dax hands yeah how did it
look not great too many I think I start
something again oh you did look at you
yes you're you're very good here alright
so let me see here Panthers always been
good at zone there man is what has
impressed me number four were Prescott
ball not coming out of hand clean
everything a little slow and the scheme
gives him nothing easy it makes the
scheme gives him nothing to make it easy
but even completions don't look great so
when dak Prescott came to the league yes
he was good enough to win Rookie of the
Year we're not gonna get unto who if he
should have won a ready Quentin but now
people are going dak his trash that's
not true he's probably somewhere in the
middle right so what is dak Prescott
right now I mean he's like
a middle-of-the-road NFL starting
quarterback with no creative scheme or
weapons at receiver to really help him
out so then it makes him look like he
may be he's the 25th quarterback in
football which he's not you know he's it
less creative than Green Bay or Seattle
um they have a more creative run game
but the pass game notes about the same
it's what kind of stuff are we seeing I
mean just uh repeat concepts too much I
thought we would call arches or eff
angle in the NFL like tight end runs a
shallow cross slot guy bends out and
runs like what they call an angle route
yeah and then the two guys on the
outside run comebacks or go routes
whatever and they're doing that how many
times I mean I would say really they go
do it almost any time it's a clutch
situation but I would bet you like in
this game they ran that five times right
and it was five times a lot yeah I mean
if it hasn't got to open and I worked
once I would say yeah maybe the second
time you call it or they're good
offenses running the same plays like
that I know unless it's working like you
know hey we saw we saw Brady throw seam
routes to Rob Gronkowski right well they
were like then we threw for 25 let's try
to do it 125 more okay let's keep doing
it yeah that's when you go back to the
well but yes it's very concerning the
lack of creativity on offense let alone
who the hell's are to be scared of I
mean when that what you wrote down was
there one shot downfield I don't think
there was one never wasn't one shot
downfield except for and you'll remember
this play where he runs up in the pocket
and he tried to throw it to the tight
end man through it like five yards so
that's the first thing he has to stop
doing when he gets them moves up in the
pocket he attacks the line of scrimmage
like he's gonna run that's not what
Brady and Rodgers do they kind of
shuffle up and stay in that position and
then okay if you continue to backup then
they tuck it and go right where do but
he he's missing opportunities there
because he's putting himself in a
running position then he's going oh my
god she's open and he's trying to get it
out and he can't get enough power or
torque on the ball issues with his
fundamentals you wrote he has no
shoulder town turned yeah so the nose
dives on the ball a lot of warm burners
and you said that like Mariota
he's his arm is an independent conscious
you know if you're watching on video
where it's just there's
no flow to the throw like you see from a
Brady or Rogers there's none of that
sometimes he just gets stuck there and
he just goes on big and strong and I'm
gonna make it happen gonna do it all
with my all with your arm and hey
there's this be doing that two years ago
no he was definitely a little bit more
of a rhythm passer that way so how does
this change because if you don't stay on
yourself in the NFL and continue to dive
into those little technical aspects on
yourself they can get lost in the NFL
because now I'll swing itself yes and
because and a lot of the coaches they
don't know how to throw a football so
they can't really teach him what he's
doing right or wrong they don't even
know and so that's what that was a
little concerning I also say with the
Cowboys offense they get they try to be
too cute sometimes like you're the
Dallas Cowboys your old line is still
good rub the frickin ball there's no
excuse for Ezekiel Elliott I only have
seven rushes in the first half there's
none they had see this is where this is
where coaches are just annoying
sometimes they had a few runs early in
the game and you read my notes where it
was they're like like oh gosh here he
goes and Kuechly just got him more fun
yes like and I just go man if it's not
like Kuechly
that play was blocked in Ezekiel oh it's
gonna get 40 yards but then they gave up
on it and then they don't run the ball
for the next eight plays so to me the
Cowboys they almost seem like they're
coming out going we're gonna throw the
ball to back you off so our run game
works just run the ball and make people
commit to stopping it and be a little
stubborn with it you said Carolina
pretty much said f you and you said
Bradbury and this Dante Jackson kid have
changed the defense changed the defense
Carolina's been primarily a zone
defensive team ever since Ron Rivera's
there I mean even when Josh Norman was
there a very rarely played man-to-man
but Dante Jackson can stay in anybody's
hip pocket I mean he's like a like a
Denzel Ward that I'm gonna find out yeah
yeah and then Bradbury is extremely good
too so they don't play a ton of man but
let's just say let's say in the old days
they ran nine places zone and one play a
man now out of those ten plays it's like
six to four and it's chant yeah or maybe
seven to three but a long though
to where I go okay they can they can
lock up some receivers and especially
when there's not one guy on the field
Hearns Gallup Terrence Williams where
those kind of corners are like okay yeah
they're not gonna run by me the the
other bad stuff that you noticed Connor
Williams didn't look that great to you
the new guard and you don't know if he's
got enough legs and ass ouch that's the
scariest thing that Sims can say about a
player that is at the guard position in
the NFC where there's a lot of ass at
defense a tackle and you got Fletcher
Cox I mean he just he had issues with
Kawana shirt and Don Terry Poe and all
of them you know he still can be a good
player but I do question his ability to
anchor in against those powerful D
tackles come on short had his way with
him the one thing I will say though that
people need to realize about the
Patriots is excuse me the Cowboys they
did hold the Panthers to 14 points the
defense did play well Cam Newton was
under a lot of pressure for a defense
that did not have David Irving and that
lost Rainey Gregory to a concussion I
thought that the linebackers Shawn Lee
and Jaylon Smith played really well look
good on Aaron Jones is looking good at
corner and at safety whatever used to
play I thought and and I thought the
coaching at the end of the game was
despicable I think in my mind you're an
offense that's been unable to really do
anything all game right it's fourth and
ten you're at the 50 you have all three
timeouts and you have the two-minute
warning hunt the ball punt the ball I
know what makes you think the Dallas
Cowboys that you could convert a fourth
and 10 I agree what makes you think punt
the ball stop him again and then get the
ball to 50 again first down and you'll
still have you'll have that you'll have
one timeout problem I mean I'm with you
lefke when did you grow this confidence
to go we got this I don't make all they
I think they ran the exact play that
you're talking about that come back on
the left side and he missed me do it
over you threw it high yes I know I'm
with you that was the baddest emergency
way okay exactly right I'm with you
there too that just shows you coaches
panic sometimes but your but your thing
is more it's not as much on dad
right as it is the offensive line had a
bad game there's no weapons at wide
receiver right or
tight end and the scheme hasn't been
good no it's like it's more of the
coaching and the personnel that it is
DAC I do I'm not gonna sit here and go
oh it's dak Prescott yeah he needs to
improve some things but hey everybody
even the Brady's and the Rogers
sometimes need here's a cheap completion
to get it going here's something easy
just to get you in rhythm sometimes
Steph Curry needs a pick so he can get a
wide-open three to get it going I mean I
don't care who you are and there's just
nothing for him in the juban Jimmy's
four there's no gimmies everything is
jam it in there or hang in the pocket
forever and hopefully you can jam it in
zone coverage somewhere and that's just
frustrating to watch is that there's any
of that gonna change um or did I just
make or do we make really bad picks on
the Dallas Cowboys win the NFC East I'm
a little scared I think we find a mall
though scared and I messed up about the
Falcons one in the south
I'm not gonna give up on that old line
yet though I still think that oh I mean
Carolina is a great matchup for them
like I wrote in my notes Carolina ain't
afraid to play big boy football against
the Cowboys say it was that's why I said
when I took Dallas I went Carolina wants
to play in the box but the problem is is
they're faced the Dallas is facing the
Giants I know and their front name was
good exactly all right last one Jimmy G
I'm seeing torn about online reaction
some people are going what the hell was
that Jimmy G I'm seeing daniil Hunter
saying he looks scared but then I'm also
seeing people with reason going they
just played maybe the best defense
defense in the NFL in Minnesota right
you come away thinking what about Jimmy
G after watching the film wasn't his
best performance certainly not locking
on wide receivers a little too often
okay
hey the Pick six was not his fault let's
just go right there
it was not his fault the receiver ran
the wrong route and I'm know because
other than him coming out and saying
that it wasn't on him oh he did say that
yeah I believe there was the receiver
already took the blame okay because I
I've never I've never seen the concept
then in the history of the sport that's
what I would say me a brand like a hitch
route and the guy from the slot was
running an out route like right by I'm
starting to the sales not that stupid to
go like oh we're gonna run
and have you guys seven feet from each
other like no and then I can also see on
film
Kyle's hands going up as the balls being
thrown and I can see Jimmy G after he
throws the interception going like this
so those little things but no I'm pretty
sure that that receiver is supposed to
run six yards and come in what we call
an under route and Jimmy G was expecting
to be there probably couldn't see it all
the way just thought he would be there
so that's why the ball looked like it
was four yards inside and you go was he
throwing it to Mike use no all right
let's pick six on his fall but overall
your thoughts on Jimmy
jet AB I have some concerns with Jimmy
with this there's two things that
concern me the locking onto the receiver
a little bit wrote that he's staring
down people man he almost killed Pierre
Garcon
I mean Pierre Gerson took like for like
concussion protocol hits and he's the
crazy Haitian and he just gets up and
doesn't bat an eye yeah but I was like
holy crap is he gonna get up and he just
gets up and like runs to the huddle is
like it doesn't even bother him and
that's what they call him out there too
so anyone wants to try to play the race
card shut up yeah ok then the other
thing here you rolling your eyes oh no
I'm Josh oh no and then the other thing
is the no hitch step did you see that in
my notes yes so you wrote this and I
started no hitch right you wrote
multiple times he's doing this without a
hitch right no hitch what does that mean
because like you see you know you talk
about like the bounce step right when I
see a quarterback that gathers down
right gather step like okay here I've
hit my fifth step in the drop my guys
open let me you know take my little crow
hop and let it go
he gets his foot flat his feet just stay
flat and he just tries to turn and throw
it it's just too hard to be accurate and
throw the ball with power like that all
the time has he always done that it's
more than I've seen him do it
but he's doing it on more throws
consistently than I'd ever seen him do
this is preseason in Game one yeah and I
thought Game one was even more than the
preseason like let's say in the
preseason I thought it was like 50/50 I
feel like it was like eight out of ten
in this game mentally what causes a
quarterback to abandon a hitch step I
think he's thinking like let me just get
the ball to my hand quick and get it
into the receivers hands
I thought it was over every route they
were they were everywhere they were I
mean the defense is special like you
said but at the same time holy crap did
they have a lot of people wide open -
who wrote man can Kyle get them open
holy [ __ ] I mean it's unbelievable I
mean just think about juice avec juice
of juicy you know au Jack I'll use yes
think about Kittel dropping the long
ball down the end zone think about what
is the other one I'm thinking about you
know Dante Pettis catching the long one
up the left sideline and then going for
like those are like Kyle being a
brilliant coach and just going here if
you hit him yeah we got 40 yards he's
George kid all had a few were like
nobody knows what he's around him right
so and then I forget who the broadcaster
was but he was like you know we like we
call that a no shoot play oh sure I
heard say that - I know you did write
that two of his three picks were bad yes
two of the three picks were bad the
Xavier Road slant right he throws that
but even threw that ball three feet in
front of the receiver
and again kind of just sit there
flatfoot and then tries to go huh real
fast and throw it it's like it's like
taking a golf swing on the driver and
going I'm gonna go back real smooth and
then I'm gonna go really fast forward
like you're yeah you might hit a 300
down the middle every now and then but I
bet you like more times than not you're
gonna be like on the fairway either side
of that where you're supposed to be
getting it so you leave the Niners
Vikings game feeling what about the
Niners offense I I still feel good about
their offense I do let's think about
this he misses a wide open George Kittel
in the end zone the games 24 213 it's
gonna be 24 20 with eight minutes left
in the fourth quarter
I mean he's wide open you can't get any
more wide open in the NFL first and goal
from the one Alfred Morris fumbles
recovers his own fumble 2nd and goal
from the 1 fumbles Minnesota gets it
yeah
Minnesota I felt like had three goal
line stands in the game yeah yeah the
Niners were knocking on the door that's
why I leave that game and I actually
feel good about the Niners and I feel a
little bit bad about the Viking so you
know what it came back to did you read
the all my notes with the air the you
know I probably did I just forgot I I it
was the third quarter and it was beep
if any subs came in for the defensive
line so you mean the starters for the
Vikings play the entire first three
quarters I mean it was unbelievable I
just don't know how they can expect to
keep that up those four guys the way
they relate I know and they don't really
have people to rotate it's just not that
many people like it really scares me
issue yes and that's why in the fourth
quarter
that's why San Francisco kept hanging
around because Minnesota was running out
of gas every time I look it up I mean
luckily for them Harrison Smith had a
huge sack and then the intercept yes
right but which was a bad horrible
decision there he is flat foot trying to
throw a tight end down the middle of the
field he stared at him the whole time
yeah Herron Smith just read his eyes and
that's where you have like hey if you're
gonna make those type of throws you've
got to take the hitch net you got to
throw it 100 miles per hour you can't
think I'm gonna get it in there with the
88 mile-per-hour change oh no it's gonna
get picked so those are all the things
there's still with other plays and
throws that were absolutely phenomenal
the threat John passed upon oh my gosh
no throwing crossbody rolling to the
left yes to Pettis and that was a great
catch by that it was Pettis showed that
he's got some skill I mean I know that
was Kyle's guy and he's got somebody
there for sure but yeah I just think
those are things that need to be cleaned
up by Jimmy gee I don't know what the
verdicts are for the offensive line
injuries I know that they lost they go
yeah Mike person got hurt and then Josh
Garnett got carted off right and then
guys I know they had a move McGlinchey
into guard Wow and then they had to put
Garrett Gilliam at a right tackle
so when you factor all of that in right
and they lost to the to the Vikings by
eight I mean it's a pretty impressive
showing by the Niner I think so
I mean I I think considered right I I
actually felt good a pick six you lose
multiple offensive line yeah Wow
yeah I know and multiple throws to be
made that weren't hit or that rhombi
killer right
and I wrote towards the end of the
fourth quarter I wrote they got the
Vikings on the ropes I mean I had the
Vikings on the ropes like yeah I also
want to say this I know I'm taking a lot
of shots of the Vikings there's not a
lot of teams that are gonna be able to
dice them up like Kyle no way you're
right you know yes like they're playing
Green Bay next week I know like Aaron
Aaron is gonna have a lot harder time
than Jimmy did with
because he's just gonna have to beat
them yes I know they need to run hurry
up offense from the start I don't know
but I need to run hurry up and just hope
to wear down the Vikings front so where
he can I don't all right let's get to
levy on bail great job with the notes
Thanks I hope that helped people so dak
is is playing middle of the road right
now but Manny doesn't have talent and
the coaches are really and the offensive
line was not good it was a bad matchup
with Carolina Fitzgerald excuse me
Fitzpatrick you see a lot of hope for
them right now but at the same point the
Saints were just playing too much man a
man and they do have talent on Tampa Bay
yeah and we'll see what happens with
Fitzpatrick but if you're reading the
trends he's going to come back to earth
yeah and the Saints I mean what we saw
last year let's just not forget they
sucked in Week one against Minnesota on
the road week two they got killed by the
New England Patriots at home so why I'm
kind of like in Cleveland and week -
yeah it's it's scary and then Jimmy gee
you actually take a lot he needs to he
needs to get a hitch step back yes and
he needs to stop throwing flat-footed
but overall if they weren't playing a
team like Minnesota yeah
maybe they'd be hanging right Le'Veon
Bell mm-hmm levy on bail I don't know
you're not a Twitter guy after the game
tweeted a magnifying glass and then came
out and said I was just saying that
because I haven't seen a tie before no
way what I don't believe you here's an
interesting statistic with Le'Veon Bell
it's been 33 games they win sixty nine
point seven percent of the time and they
averaged twenty three point nine points
per game without levy on bail in the
last three years 16 games they've a
winning percentage of 75 percent and
they averaged twenty eight point eight
points per game that's five more
percentage wins
that's nearly five more points per game
and they also averaged 48 yards per game
more without Le'Veon Bell it's
interesting yes in the same day that
James Connor goes out there and has a
monster game
David Johnson signs a new contract three
years 39 million could get up to 45 with
30 guaranteed
so in essence taking 13 a year Le'Veon
Bell is older than David he's slower
than David he doesn't catch the ball as
good as David that one is close that one
is close and the team that he's holding
out for is playing very well with James
Connor I'm seeing a lot of people online
saying that this is all the agents fault
to blame and that levian needs to stop
mainly because the agents been in the
media so much and that levian needs to
get back out there what do you think is
going on with Le'Veon I got a press
release emailed to me from a club in
Miami saying levian was at our club
Saturday night what is going on I don't
think he's showing up to week 9 or 10 I
don't you really just readin everything
yeah I think so I think that's why the
steelers came out the way they did last
week I think James Conner scored a
touchdown yeah he chest-bumped every
offensive lime in that first time right
they all came up to him we're going nuts
right it seems like they've mentally
moved on from life I mean they have to
right now they can't worry about Merson
right they can't and you know yeah first
of all this Steelers offense is still
gonna be special and good let me know
one guy is gonna make this offense this
office it's a good scheme it's a very
good offensive line and they still got
receivers and big bends so and the
biggest thing is I'm not gonna sit here
and go James corner as good as let me on
bail cuz he's not but his skill set
allows them to run the same scheme so
they don't have to change their offense
he can do everything levy on Ken just at
a lesser level so when I look at it from
that standpoint I just go okay
the Steelers are still gonna be good
they're still gonna be dangerous it's
not gonna matter whether Lebanon bells
there or not yeah I have no no qualms
about it and it hurt them yesterday that
that field was like that rainy and messy
come on they're the team that wants to
throw the ball around a lot they're the
team that has this he's behind in the 50
to eat times in a monsoon right so there
you go
it was
and he missed some throws and it was wet
and he got unlucky
you know people yelling at him for
interceptions and I'm gonna go with only
one of them was his fault but so you
believe that levee ons gonna be at at
least nine weeks yeah and I got no
problem with it well of course I know
we've talked about a lot I mean it's a
dangerous position a D D is a reporter
for the NFL and she tweeted let's not
forget this levee on bells teammates
have had his back through one arrest two
suspensions two offseason holdouts
they've had his back when he showed up
late to a playoff walk through his
threatening retirement and the strip
club video there you go
it really is an interesting dynamic it
is because he's a very special player
but when you put all of that on a piece
of paper right and you think about all
the things that he that the team a--
stood by him for and a Antonio Brown
came out last week and said I support my
brother Antonio Brown a levy on bail
right
it's it stinks I think we're we all this
is where what happens we haven't talked
about this let's say he sits out nine
yeah and he comes back in week ten
yeah are they even gonna want him back
yes they are but they're not gonna make
a big deal and like really like they're
not gonna be like oh gosh you're back
let's get back to doing a lot of things
on the offense around it they're just
gonna be like okay let's go out to
practice and you get yourself in shape
and you know you still start James at
that play definitely definite so I mean
he won't start here you know they're
really they're just gonna go okay let's
get him going make him part of the
rotation could they put him on special
teams I doubt that because I'm sure at
some point he's gonna that's where he's
gonna go what no I won't do that we
talked about how Odell had to be the
Good Samaritan for the Giants to pay
yeah for levy on I'm hearing reports
that Pittsburgh wants him back I don't
think there's any way there's any way no
he's gonna be on a new team next year
you know there's obviously issues with
the guaranteed money and I know the
Pittsburgh Steelers have a weird
organizational philosophy about giving
guaranteed money just like we saw with
Antonio Brown Eli give me 19 million
Guerra
it's a good rest of his contract there
was only 19 million guaranteed for
injury and everything so if he got hurt
he's screwed oh okay well I'm a running
back that gets the ball man like almost
400 times a year between catches and
runs yeah and he's going you're not
gonna give me big time guarantees then
he's scared he's hurt and I understand
that this is a guy let's not forget that
lost you know hurt his knee with bond
tez Burke back to hurting him a few
years ago just to get back to the David
Johnson contract I actually love that
contract for both teams yeah David
Johnson getting 13 million a year as a
base is a good number for a guy that
just missed an entire season
30 million guaranteed so literally it
seems like four of fifths of his
contract is guaranteed but the thing I
like about the most it's a three-year
deal no he goes effect he goes two years
and we're ready to renegotiate this was
gonna happen
he's it's a two-year 30 million dollar
deal boy short and sweet you're exactly
right it's a two-year 30 million dollar
deal and if he's still playing good
they're gonna go hey let's do the same
thing again give it three years 45
another 30 million that's 60 million
over four years exactly right and if you
give the Garrett the guarantees are what
these running backs are looking they
just want they want some safety again
just think about being a running back in
the NFL run up the middle
oh what your [ __ ] hits me in the thigh
run up the middle Oh looky CLE hit me in
the ribs right on the outside going on
the outside Oh some guys trying to chop
my legs out from under me at Landon
Collins oh oh wait it's a bullets and
here comes Bobby Wagner full speed and I
have to stop him in my in his tracks and
I can't even run in him I gotta just sit
there and hold my ground it's the most
physically demanding position in all of
sports and it's a such a short shelf
life you have to have compassion for it
a one-story so if you guys don't realize
every Sunday morning the reporters the
national reporters the Rappaport's the
chef ders and all that they save these
juicy little nuggets and they drop them
at like 6:00 or 7:00 in the morning and
my theory is they're trying to own the
news cycle for all those pregame shows
Glaser too and they put out these
stories and they try and take over the
story because as soon as 12:00 happens
the inactive scum out and everyone's
focused on Fantasyland and betting and
gambling that the stories don't matter
why don't they get these things out
there in like Saturday or Friday
sometimes though this is how the news
works it's gonna eventually creep back
and creep back they used to save it for
noon right they used to save it for
those shows then they realized there's
not enough traction the game start at
1:00 now they're back to 8:00
it's gonna I was I wake up Sunday
morning and my Bleacher Report app is
packed with alerts it's gonna start
coming out Saturday night and then it's
gonna start coming out Saturday morning
but but you know why doesn't come out
Saturday night cuz you don't wanna
compete with college football they're
trying to find the windows and they
found the windows and the big story that
came out Andrew Luck got hurt in a
snowboarding accident and no one's
talking about it now because now all the
games are out there and had quotes from
Andrew Luck
you went conspiracy theory what do you
think's going on well I just think like
it's first of all it's odd I mean yeah
he gets the snow we refresh my memory
refresh everybody's memory
what was the timeline with the shoulder
injury and stuff I don't remember
right so the it happened in the after
the 2015 season right when he has the
snowboarding injury so it's 2016 when he
has the shoulder injury now 2016 he
plays football and at the end of the
year he gets beat up and all of a sudden
we have a shoulder injury doesn't play
2017 right so you know and you know
supposedly he's saying oh that that had
nothing to do with the labrum and the
and the shoulder injury from the
snowboarding well not you know I hobby
16 was his worst year as a pro right and
I'm not in 2016 he wasn't horrible was
he I mean it was like still like 31 and
13 I'm telling it was something like
that yeah look it up keep I got it I'm
already here I've already beat you so
here it is right here that year he had
where the hell is he here oh hi Alan
2017 sorry now I'm here I guess I gotta
gotta gotta gotta get a good here we go
so that year yet 31 and 13 I was correct
okay okay that's the worst year right
but record wise I know they weren't as
good right he couldn't carry them all
the time that's what they needed I know
and and it um so yeah I just have a hard
time Billy
what that didn't do the labrum then well
whatever you hurt your shoulder and did
you get out I'm RI after that
snowboarding incident like did you get
it I'm I have to see those things before
I kind of believe that story let alone
yes then he does hurt the labrum and
missus football but it's also like the
big problem there too and what we've
always I think I've addressed this
before his buddy from Stanford did the
surgery on his shoulder he didn't go to
a shoulder specialist you've never said
this I never said that no cuz when you
said that to me this morning I went wait
what
so Andrew Luck had a quote unquote
snowboarding hinge right in 2015 yeah
after the season right and then went to
his Stanford buddy and got surgery not
then when he opened the labrum thing
accidentally six that's when he went he
got the Stanford guy that was his friend
why is that an issue well I just think
that's rare first of all there's a lot
of shoulder specialists in this country
I mean there's dr. James Andrews or some
of those cut type of guys or and you
just go to your friend or the Colts yeah
so to me it was like was there something
more in there that you didn't really
want anybody the team affiliated to see
that's where my conspiracy there is is I
have no knowledge of that with the rig
it's very fishy so you and your in your
mind go you went to your friend to hide
it to hide some facts what I'm saying if
I'm a bigger dog right which is amazing
to me because Andrew Luck seems too
honest yeah
Andrew Luck after the game in a jacket
that's like three sizes too big have you
noticed this yet he looks like
beetlejuice with a shrunken head all the
time I feel like he lost a bunch of
weight and was like I don't need new
suits you have $100,000,000 get a new
suit seriously man but he after the game
he was like I was really overwhelmed
like Andrew Luck I'm really happy to be
here guys I can't imagine him lying and
hold him withholding stuff I think mr.
honest a I know yes I know I just think
it's very weird you serious man you
think he's possibly hiding I do I do I
think so I just I mean I just can't take
his word to go oh nothing happened in
that I hurt my shoulder bread there was
no labrum tear like oh okay
okay and you told us you'd be back for
the 2017
season as well but that didn't happen so
I don't know you know just those are
things I think about when I try to
connect dots and I've been around the
league a long time to see stupid crap
like that happen also call me crazy yeah
if I had to guess that Andrew Luck was
on the slopes I definitely thought he'd
be a skier than a snow I wouldn't have
pictured that either I don't see Andrew
Luck is shredding gnar eyed I see him
being like a pizza pie ski guy and being
like oh that first run was good enough
for me guys I'll be back making some
quiche I'll see in the lodge hopefully
the hot tubs not too bubbly for ya like
he's Russell Wilson without Ciara
yeah yeah yeah yes he is every bit the
way like when you meet him in person
that he is that's him like you said
there's no act can't you see Andrew Luck
falling down and having a snot bubble be
like god it's cold out here I could well
I just like the fact that he tells
people good hit but can you believe
they're dangerous though still with him
one again I said this again yeah member
they went into 9 of their 16 games and
they're awful year last year I'm eating
in the fourth quarter and right away
we're leading in the fourth quarter yes
the cults just hang around they do and
that roster stinks I mean but you you
believe Colts at home there are
different they're a different team with
him at the helm too and yeah I believe
they were gonna go down in the field he
was gonna stay were gonna score a
touchdown that's my colleagues and then
he fumbles the ball off go lock I do
I'll phone was the ball but yeah they're
just never out of it with him hey he's
fearless he's a fearless thrower the
football he's fearless in the pocket
yeah and you can see he's still fearless
running the ball to quick fan things
before we go one Joe tits band with a
random question yo what is the largest
animal you think you could catch if it
was fired out of a cannon and you had to
stay standing
oh the largest animal that you could
catch fired out of a cannon and you
couldn't fall down after you caught it
yeah I think I'd like to think I could
like man up on like a smaller Labrador
Labrador type of dog so you think of a
small dog like an ox well that's like a
beat like a 60 pound
yeah you think of a 60-pound now I might
have two grams to really like hold my
ground but I want to think I can I knew
it I feel like if I could take like
Julius Peppers to the chest I can take a
dog to the chest
you can stay standing I think I don't
know I don't even know cuz what's it
gonna Canada's I mean I don't know
either I mean yeah how fast is the
cannon shooting out there I know I feel
like watch you now people and they don't
they go 20 feet and they fall down I
don't know you swore that feet yeah I
don't know Evel Knievel's going like 50
yards well that's a different kind of
Canada you're right that's a special one
I said what do you think I don't know I
don't think about that fat guy that
takes a cannonball right to the stomach
and he's like Oh entertainment used to
be weird I don't know I kind of thought
about a bird yeah I don't know I mean I
hope you can catch a bird that was
dropping hey nothing I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go with I'm gonna go with a medium
sized cat a medium sized cat but then
I'm scratched oh yeah call the crap out
of you Joe you have a weird brain I
don't know where he thought thank you
yeah I'm just imagining Joe being like
smaller Labrador Labrador and then goes
into his basement and puts one in his
can and he's like I can do it he's been
doing it for years not one of those like
Labradors that you know people feed too
much and you go damn that dogs like 50
pounds overweight random question when
you see overweight dogs do you judge the
owner a little bit yes definitely
Carlos is my last question interesting
question I see Rogers break the huddle
and the majority of the time he's fixing
his chin strap and then he shrugs his
shoulders
yeah kind of like a ritual of sorts
right is that common for quarterbacks
and did you have a ritual of your own uh
yeah he kind of touches his chin
straight well he always yeah he's always
got it like one thing he does that and
then yeah he does do that
I mean think about Peyton Manning all
the twitches he had even he lie every
time you like there was a ball he he
throws the ball does this every single
time readjust his shoulder pads clicks
both of his hands and then pulls out his
shoulder pads every time is that before
or after that's after so I think before
what are the ticks do you pick up on
like up on all this yeah I do I mean
what about Brady Brady No
you know I don't notice too many ticks
with Brady brainy's got a lot on his
plate cuz bills like there's 90 rules
for this play so just get them right and
I like the breeze so Brees throws in its
lick lick shoulder pad yeah down Eli its
let me Center my head and loosen up
right right it's like a weird shimmy he
does but yeah pay attention to it does
it every time did you have anything you
know Payton used to go like all shucks
and then he'd pull up his thigh pad
every time every time like every did he
really say all shucks
I you know him all [ __ ] his picture up
saying do you think you had any probably
did you just didn't even realize yeah
I'm sure I did I wonder if Brees and
Brady realized it and he like realized I
would think somebody's pointed it out to
them by now going up the line of
scrimmage let me just think if I read it
I mean I definitely know I was this guy
and you're playing in freakin Tampa and
you're blowing heat into your just want
to get that moisture right in my hand
that's how I wasn't breathing or if I
would or I would maybe wet my towel like
you have the towel there by your crotch
I would wet that just a little bit to
have oh just a little moisture
especially be to go like Carolina in
November it might be dry and cool or
whatever I was like and I was used to
Tampa in the humidity yeah I'd have to
get a little moisture on my hand you're
like one of those ethical back and watch
yeah I had a guy bow Trahan in Texas I'm
in a session two people he was like a
safety special teams guy he had a did
this all the time you know say we're in
an audio book he would take his thumb
and he would put it into his right
nipple but every night and would it be
in one time or what he just like keep
doing it he do it all the time and I was
like dude do you know you do this all
the time and he was like you know I've
been noticing lately yeah
yeah he was just like a ticky hat he
would do it all the time he would
literally rub himself raw right below
his right nipple like skin would come
yeah I mean he'd be trouble you take his
shirt off and you'd be like damn he's
got like a red like mark there but the
true thing is is that all humans do
things repetitively and don't realize
right if you really were to record you
taking a shower getting out of the
shower and doing your own morning I'm
almost positive that we don't even
realize we do the same oh that's why for
me I take different ways to work
I hear that is i healthy for you I
change my routine right if I see if I
get onto a train car and I see the same
person from a few days before I go god
dammit my routine is so I don't even
realize it Here I am thinking I'm little
messing my life don't mess with my I'm
getting all my train and I'm getting on
the same car and they're getting on
three stops later which means they had
the same routine this morning - that
[ __ ] freaks me out yeah it freaks me out
routine can be good though I know well
I'm trying to get into routine for my
job and it's helping I feel like I'm a
little bit better at my job you are at
the same point I'm I hate it yeah I know
you're they sound like my wife my wife's
always like that like I don't like a
routine except when it comes down to my
massages my nail appointments and
shopping and then I'm all for routine
perfect guys thank you so much again the
second episode of The Sims and Lefko the
show comes out Wednesday at 8 p.m. we're
at like over 400,000 views on YouTube
right now whoa big offseason normal
Wednesday podcast will be out Thursday
morning yes Thursday mornings dress out
and me and Lefko are not scripted on
this damn show we're just that good so
that was so funny I pissed me off
comments like man this shows a little
script and I'm like no we really don't
have scripts at all like in fact they
don't even tell us what to say no we
change it every time no that's how I
know like I'm around you too much
because you're you can finish my sensei
sandwiches all right for six I'm left go
oh sorry
foursome peace out homies off enteric
goody-goody good New Year Happy New Year
happy Rosh Hashanah everybody he's the
the Jew that follows and I I just want
to make podcast be it and for the lef
koe man Shanah Tovah
well how aren't you guys later enjoy the
show Wednesday's a p.m. please hello